DNA heals a lot of attention as it stores
our genetic information, and deserves it.
If we did not have DNA, there would be no way
to store the information that makes us who we are,
and the other organisms what they are.
DNA has some useful properties, it can replicate,
which we have discussed in detail in other videos.
DNA can also produce DNA,
we call this replication. But only the replication of DNA
is not enough
to create a new organism.
To create a new organism you must
to take the DNA and DNA information
with it to produce structural molecules,
enzymes, transport molecules, signal molecules,
who do the work in the body.
The first step in this process
we have spoken in other videos.
The first step is to get DNA from the DNA,
namely, information RNA.
This process here
is called transcription.
We talk about the transcription in detail
in other videos.
Then the information RNA
goes to ribosomes and interacts with transport RNA,
which carries amino acids that form proteins.
Thus, from information RNA,
using transport RNA
and amino acids - Let's say "+ mRNA" and "amino acids".
I will write "amino acids" in a brighter color.
Because we will be focusing on this video.
mRNA and amino acids can construct proteins (proteins).
We can build proteins,
which consist of amino acid chains.
Proteins are the ones that
doing a lot of work in the body.
Proteins are just amino acid chains,
and sometimes they are made by
several amino acid chains.
Imagine that this is an amino acid.
This is another amino acid.
This is another.
This is another, we can continue.
These amino acid chains,
based on the properties of
individual amino acids determine
how proteins are formed,
how they interact with the environment
and what function they perform.
Proteins can build virtually everything part of the immune system -
antibodies, enzymes, even
signaling hormones such as insulin.
They participate in the muscle contraction.
Aktin and myosin for which we have
great video, are proteins.
Proteins are involved in the transport of oxygen -
hemoglobin is a protein.
Proteins
do a lot of work.
DNA says what the hereditary information contained,
but much of the work in the body is actually
is made of proteins.
And as we have said, the building blocks
the proteins are amino acids.
Let's focus on it for a moment.
Here are examples of amino acids here.
There are 20 frequent, sputtered amino acids,
there are a few, depending on which organism we look at.
And theoretically, there may be many more.
But in most biological systems,
there are 20 commonly distributed amino acids that are encoded in DNA.
Here are two of them.
Let's first concentrate on their similarities.
We see that both, in fact, all three,
have an amino group.
We have an amino group
and that's why we call them amino acids.
We have an amino group.
The amino group is here.
Now you can say, "It's called an amino acid,"
"where does the acid come from?"
"Acid" comes from the carboxyl group here.
That's why we call them heartburns.
This carboxyl group is acidic.
He can deliver a proton.
In the middle we have carbon,
we call this carbon atom - alpha carbon.
We call it alpha carbon.
Alpha carbon, this alpha carbon is bound,
it forms a covalent bond with the amino group,
covalent bond to the carboxyl group
and a covalent bond with a hydrogen atom.
From now on, we have differences
between different amino acids. Actually, there is even
and some exceptions for nitrogen,
but for the most part the differences
between the amino acids are in that with what
alpha carbon forms its fourth covalent bond.
You see that in serin we have this,
which we can call alcohol.
We can have alcohol as a side chain.
We have in the valley
pure hydrocarbon, hydrocarbon side chain.
We can generally call these side chains
R groups. These R groups
play a major role in determining the shape of proteins,
how they interact with the environment
and what features they perform.
Even only of these examples here, you can guess
how different side chains can have different behaviors.
Amino acid with side chain alcohol -
we know that oxygen is electronegative
and likes to pull electrons - It's remarkable
how many chemical and even biological properties we can predict
only by electrification.
Oxygen attracts electrons, so
we will have a partial negative charge here.
Hydrogen has low electrical resistance compared to oxygen,
so he can supply his electrons
and will have a partial positive charge.
We also have polarity,
i. the molecule will be hydrophilic.
At least that part of the molecule will be able to
to attract and interact with water.
Compared to serine
here we have a hydrocarbon side chain that is not polar.
It will be hydrophobic.
When we start talking about the structure of
proteins and how
is influenced by the side chains,
imagine that parts of the protein,
which have hydrophobic side chains,
will be in the interior of the protein,
if they are in aqueous solution.
And those who are hydrophilic,
will want to stand in the outer part of the protein.
There may also be side chains that are
large and bulky,
they will be difficult to pack.
Other side chains will be small,
making them easy to pack.
The side chains can define the shape of the protein.
We will talk about it more when
we talk about the structure of proteins.
But how do amino acids interact with each other?
We will look at this issue in more detail
in another video.
But if we have serin here,
and here we have valine,
they are linked by the so-called peptide bonds.
A peptide bond is a term that is used when two or more amino acids are linked.
This will be a dipeptide, and the relationship -
It's not that big, it will actually
I draw again, smaller.
So ...
This is a serine.
It's valine.
They form a peptide bond, and this will be the smallest one
peptide - dipeptide.
Peptide, peptide bond or
peptide coupling.
And this chain forms a polypeptide.
We can add more
and more amino acids to it.
This may be a protein
or a portion of a protein.
The last thing I want to talk about is
the way these amino acids are drawn.
They are drawn, as you can often see in a textbook.
But at physiological pH, pH in the body
which is about 7,
roughly - between 7.2 and 7.4.
In this situation, the carboxyl group here
will probably be deprotonated,
will probably deliver hydrogen.
This is more common.
The concentration of the deprotonated form will be greater
from that of the protonated.
Physiological conditions are more likely
this oxygen will accept these two electrons
and have a negative charge.
The hydrogen proton is separated.
Oxygen has taken the electrons of hydrogen.
And then
amino group at physiological pH
will probably connect to a proton.
Nitrogen has a free electron pair
and can use it to connect to a proton.
In fact, at physiological pH
you will find a higher concentration of nitrogen connected
with a proton compared to nitrogen that is not.
Nitrogen has captured a proton,
using his free e-pair.
So there will be a positive charge.
Sometimes you may encounter the amino acids described
in this way, which is actually more accurate
for physiological conditions.
These molecules have an interesting name.
A molecule that is neutral, though
its individual parts are loaded,
is called zwitterion.
A funny word, is not it?
Zwitterion.
"Zwitter" in German means "hybrid",
and "ion" obviously means there will be a charge.
This will be a hybrid charge,
although there are charges at these ends,
they are added to 0.